what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today i have a pretty cool halloween-ish
style video for you because i don't
normally post on sundays which is going
to be halloween i'm going to talk about
it today we have a description of what
andrew garfield's and toby mcguire's
costumes are going to look like along
with the green goblins costume in
spider-man no way home also a tiny
description of the black and gold suit
that tom holland will be wearing at one
point in time in the movie so in true
halloween spirit we will be talking
about the costumes of all of these
people in this video and if you're new
and you want to stay up to date on the
mcu be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos and
so you can enter our latest giveaway for
a chance to win a crazy cool spider-man
bring variant arts action figure all you
have to do to enter subscribe to my
channel and my other channel cosmic
culture ran by chris just drop some
comments on some recent videos so this
is a verified description coming from
reddit the mods have seen the photos but
cannot post them but the leak is
confirmed to be verified and like i said
the descriptions of the full costumes
worn by toby maguire andrew garfield and
willem dafoe and spiderman no way home
we're gonna start with toby's it says
toby's costume is basically the same as
it was in the original trilogy we were
able to see it being worn as well as
hanging next to tom and andrew's suit
the colors look a bit more vibrant but
it could just be the lighting i'm
personally okay with this because i
actually do really enjoy the look of the
sam raimi toby maguire spider-man suit
and if you're going to bring him back i
kind of want him to look exactly the
same maybe the face obviously look a bit
older because some time has passed and
obviously tobey maguire's gotten older
but i would really like the suit to
actually be the same to be the same
spider-man per se that we saw from the
other universe so this is exciting to me
and should be exciting for andrew
garfield amazing spider-man fans as well
because it says andrew's costume is
basically the same as it was in the
amazing spider-man 2 as well we were
only able to see it hanging next to the
other suits but we can confirm and
matches the costume in the leaked video
of andrew garfield i think most people
have seen that leaked video by now i've
even done a few videos on it myself
after it was pretty much in the general
public for everybody to see and in this
leaked video the costume looked awesome
andrew garfield looked awesome and i'm
really excited to see him back as
spider-man with toby maguire alongside
of tom holland now the green goblin's
costume apparently is not going to look
exactly the same it says green goblin's
costume is the raimi suit with an
updated design it's somewhat damaged and
patchy and a few minor adjustments have
been made it includes add-ons like a
comic accurate tan colored shoulder
strap and belt with a bomb bag some gold
colored accessories on his legs and some
scattered purple accessories like a
cloth wrapped around his arm metallic
exoskeleton looking parts fill in some
of the damaged parts and the thighs the
costume is still almost entirely green
it's still very clearly the raimi suit
from 2002 just with add-ons no mask is
being worn in the image just black
goggles like doc ox and spider-man 2 we
also know he'll have a purple scarf hood
at some point thanks to previous leaks
i'm all for this because again pretty
much like i mentioned for toby if
they're bringing the green goblin back
and he is the same green goblin bring it
back in the same outfit now i don't mind
the upgrades at all and i actually think
each of them should probably be upgraded
but i'm okay with the spider-man's not
being upgraded however the green goblin
possibly not rocking a mask and just
rocking a hood instead i actually really
like that and i'm really really excited
that willem dafoe is returning now they
also have a tiny bit of info about tom's
black and gold suit it says also shared
with us were descriptions of an early
version of tom's black and gold suit
with bits of red in it it was a physical
suit and there's a cell phone duct tape
to the chest for some reason now when i
hear cell phone tape to the chest i
typically think bomb however i don't
think tom holland spider-man has a bomb
strapped to his chest now from what i've
been told about the black and gold suit
it's really just spider-man's black and
red suit flipped inside out so why you
would have a cell phone taped to it i'm
not really sure but it's nice that some
mystery is still left for this movie
that has just an absolutely crazy amount
of leaks going around about it but
that's it for what i'll call today's
halloween video a description of the
costumes for toby maguire andrew
garfield and willem dafoe i absolutely
cannot wait until we see these on screen
and see all three of these men returning
as their respective characters go ahead
and let me know how excited you are for
them to return in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram twitter and tick tock
hope everybody has a happy halloween and
stay safe and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you